i live with diplo right now and he
supports
my endeavors diplo and quinlan blackwell
are
speaking out after catching heat for
living together
scream scream the 19 year old tick tock
star
recently revealed in a tick tock video
that she's living at the 41 year old
dj's la home
i always see y'all saying in my comments
like do your neighbors not file noise
complaints like why does no one ever
tell you to shut up
i live with diplo right now and he
supports
my endeavors well that sparked some fan
curiosity
and concern so on sunday quinlan hit up
twitter to respond to the critics
writing quote i'm an adult i'm not being
groomed
platonic relationships exist i've been
living here for over a year
i'd rather break both of my legs and be
forced to walk
than pursue diplo romantically and he'd
rather choke
and it didn't end there the 19 year old
social media star
added that she and the musician whose
real name is thomas wesley pence
aren't in the house together that much
because he's so busy
and she praised him for giving her the
opportunity and the security to create
quote diplo and his team are my mentors
in la and they are my safety net
diplo and his team have saved me
numerous times from the weirdos in la
my parents trust him i trust him y'all
are making me feel icky
diplo is my la dad nothing more as for
diplo
he took to twitter to explain the
situation a little more
writing that he rents one of his
properties to quinlan and he uses the
studio that's in the building
quote her social media is sarcastic and
chaotic
and i can see you can get a twisted idea
but there is nothing but a friendship
between us
when one fan asked what he has in common
with a 19 year old that warrants a
friendship he wrote quote
we made music together why do i live
with you
i have no other friends shortly after
quinlan revealed the two
lived together last week she addressed
the negative press on her tick tock
dancing to cardi b's press press press
press press press
since y'all care so much about me living
with diplo i'm gonna just start a series
called living with diplo okay
yeah she also started a whole series on
her tick tock account called
living with diplo i'm living with diplo
the series
he doesn't know how to tie his shoes but
where's the other string
and you know what they seem to be
letting the hate roll right off their
[Music]
backs
this one's my fave though magical
magical magic of magical magical fossil
that's a vibe and guys it's worth noting
quinlan has a boyfriend named parker
and she posts him on her page a lot she
even recently joked about having kids
with him
on twitter posting this facetime screen
grab and writing quote
i just asked parker if we could have a
child and he said yes if he can fit a
crib in his room
and then he wouldn't stop smiling sir
i was joking not cute enough for you
well
get this she also shared this shot of
them together on twitter
along with the custom rugs he had made
in their likeness
you